there are a lot of people on the
anti-work side who don't believe in free
speech they don't believe in debating
people's ideas they believe in
destroying people there are a lot of
people who are unwilling to have a
discussion with somebody they disagree
and they spend their entire time owning
people now though I go on the BBC and
make them look bad and we'll put a clip
out but I that's not that's not who I am
and it's not what I do right and I think
generally
look it's hard to be and we talked about
earlier it's hard to be anti-something
and be constructive
I'm Dave Rubin and we are at the local
Studio here in Miami and joining me
today is the co-host of the trigonometry
podcast and author of an immigrant's
love letter to the West Constantine
kissing Constantine this is bizarre that
we have never met in person before and
it is awesome that we now have we have
what should we do now let's talk but
let's talk about stuff okay
I think some people sort of think you
are like the British version of me in a
way so what's the deal well give me a
little history listen um I'm I'm gonna
spill the beans uh I used to watch your
show religiously particularly
2017 2018. those crazy formative years
yeah and uh I thought what you were
doing was incredible uh and you showed
what was possible for somebody who is
independent minded who wanted to come in
um and you know interview interesting
people from a position or perhaps not
knowing very much and so I said to my
buddy Francis why don't we do something
like this it is genuinely seeing you and
Joe uh you know to have these
conversations was an incredible
influence and so I'm delighted to to be
here with you well I I'm glad that you
are was nobody really doing that in the
UK yet the the more independent-minded
stuff obviously there's a gajillion chat
shows and and the UK has a long history
of long-form interviews and that kind of
thing yeah I can't think of the top
there are people there are other people
who have slightly different
conversations but I think that mix of
levity with seriousness and that is
something that it's kind of interesting
because we're both former standards yeah
uh and Francis still does stand up and I
think that gives you something because
you you've always got a way to release
tension if you need to and for us it's
been very important because you know we
interviewed a woman Dr Ella Hill who's a
survivor of one of these grooming gangs
I don't know if you're familiar with
them and we interviewed her for an hour
and this isn't really anything to do
with us but nonetheless it's an
interview about a victim of the most
heinous crimes which is funny is funny
right and and that I think is is the
magic Source was she ready to be funny
about it yeah it's all down to her we
were just able to play along that's all
yeah so you're out of the stand-up game
huh yeah I I I hated the lifestyle I
enjoyed being on stage but driving
around for hours and all of that that's
funny because for me too I I love love
love doing stand up and you know I do
gigs still here and there in book tours
and that kind of thing it was never the
the being on stage or being at the
comedy clubs it was everything else it
was the life that it could lead to that
that I couldn't deal with which I think
is is why so many Comics end up on drugs
or dead basically it's a it's look there
are harder lives obviously no no no
other people and talking working in rice
fields you know getting home at 2AM uh
waking up at you know 10 the next day
it's just not it's I can't do it and now
you and I both are fathers so I it's
it's not for me when lockdown happened
in the UK it forced me to really really
evaluate it and my wife we've been
married for 20 years we have the most
beautiful relationship but I was working
so hard because we were trying to get
trigonometry off the ground we were
doing stand-up both of us Francis was oh
wow married a comic too well no my I
married a company no no I'm talking
about Francis I thought you said my wife
he said my wife we did standard she did
yeah sorry I'm maybe misspoke oh I maybe
maybe Francis is my work wife at this
point uh no what was happening was
basically both Francis and I were
working extremely hard yeah and by the
time lockdown came even though my wife
and I have a beautiful relationship it
was kind of like locked down sort of I
wouldn't say it saved our marriage but
our son certainly wouldn't have been
born without it you know what I mean
because suddenly I was like oh oh I'm at
home now and maybe maybe I should
actually spend some time with this
person that I claim to love so either I
misheard you or you referred to him as
your wife in either case one of us is
not looking very good here well it's
probably me yes probably not probably
not so for people that just that that
don't know you don't know your work uh
can you just talk a little bit about
your sort of childhood and into into
what got you into sort of the cultural
political thing that we're kind of in
the mix of and then we'll hit the the
issues of the day well the short version
of is I was born in the Soviet Union in
the late 80s uh into a family that I was
imbued from a very young age with
stories of my ancestors people who uh
starved in the gulags for saying the
wrong thing or who were really severely
punished my grandfather the way I ended
up in the UK is my parents they were
very wealthy for like three years and in
that time Gap they sent me to boarding
school in England because my grandfather
was there and the reason my grandfather
was there that there was that in the
late 70s early 80s he criticized the
Soviet invasion of Afghanistan and he
was immediately ostracized by his
friends fired from work his wife was
fired from work his children that's my
father and my aunt were kicked out of
university for him making this one
comment in private and so when it came
to living in the UK and doing stand-up
and I saw this climate that was
happening where suddenly it was very
very sudden at least to me because I
wasn't paying that much attention
suddenly words became this all-powerful
thing that would that was to be treated
with the utmost seriousness and jokes
could not be treated as jokes if you
made a joke that people didn't like they
couldn't just say oh that's not funny
now you had to be punished and in
addition to that you know the one thing
that I really as an immigrant to to the
UK I found very unpleasant was
this idea that all our social problems
whether that's you know brexit or Trump
or whatever can be explained by claiming
that people are racist and that's when I
came across your show actually because
uh I I was trying to understand because
I'd lived in England for all my most of
My Teenage life and all my adult life
and I'm a dark-skinned immigrant I
experience racism once or twice but it
was never I never felt like it was a
racist country and so when a referendum
like brexit where I voted to remain by
the way you couldn't vote for Hillary in
2016. well and Francis did too as well
we both did
when the explanation for that that was
being offered to us was that half the
country was I was just like no this is
BS this isn't true and that I think is
part of the reason that we really
started to look at these things because
we felt our own industry change and also
we looked around at society and we just
went something is off we're being told a
bunch of lies and and quite nasty ones
as well you know for Francis
particularly
um you know his father is is a is a evil
straight white man uh who married a
woman from Venezuela in the 80s when
that was not the done thing in England
uh and he voted brexit and he was he he
was suddenly demonized and it just it
that picture of the our societies is so
inaccurate that it was very frustrating
and I think trigonometry is partly born
out of that frustration right it's
interesting because I wasn't talking
about brexit that much at first but then
because of the Trump situation here I
started having a couple people from the
UK and some Americans that were talking
about brexit and then suddenly I had all
these people in the UK watching and I
was like well I didn't even intend that
to happen but there was definitely a
connection between brexit and the Trump
thing for sure there was and and the
cultural forces that swirl around those
issues are largely the same now you guys
do politics very differently to the way
that we do but fundamentally the way I
see it it was a sort of it was a
rebellion of the people uh whether it
was channeled in the right way is a
different conversation uh but people
certainly in the UK felt that a lot of
their concerns were not being not only
heard but they weren't even being aired
and so that I think is why those two
issues are very similar and did that uh
change your politics then once once you
saw the reaction to brexit I mean I
think like if I was to somewhat try to
pin you I'd guess I would say you're a
classical liberal it has a slightly
different connotation from a UK
perspective I have a hard time even
though I wrote a whole book defending
liberalism from an American perspective
it's almost ridiculous to call myself a
liberal at this point just because
people don't understand the words
anymore but did that shift your your
political ideology I think it it it
maybe did a little bit but mainly I've
become clearer about what I think when
we started trigonometry in early 2018 I
I wasn't someone who was politically
educated I studied politics in
University but it wasn't something where
I had a political philosophy yeah you
know I was a guy who did jokes about
being Russian on stage for a living
that's what I did right so it wasn't
something that I that I really had
thought about very much and that's the
beauty of what we do is we get to be
educated by our guests that's why I
really enjoy about it but in terms of
where I am now
um
it's it's hard to place because a lot of
it's a sad thing to say but a lot of
what I do is is being in opposition to
things and it's actually something I've
been thinking and talking about a lot of
getting past that because we're going to
have to but up until this point you know
I say that I reject wokeness because I'm
a liberal right that that that is my
position it's the most ill liberal
ideology out permeating throughout the
West right now right and I rejected also
because I don't believe in
discrimination and if you believe in
actual equality of opportunity and the
people should be treated equally
irrespective who they are you cannot
possibly be work it's not possible right
uh it's also not possible of course to
you know to go in the other direction
but that's about where I am and in terms
of
uh you know a more wet where I am in
terms of what I see from a positive side
it's it's much it gets much harder
because I I I don't really I'm not
ideological I sort of pick positions
based on whether that particular thing
makes sense to me you know and so on
certain things people would Place me
probably on like because now believing
in a border makes you right wing now I'm
on the right I suppose on that issue and
others I'm very liberal so socially in
particular right so uh which is odd to
me also not odd to me but it's
interesting to me to see this
realignment because here I am in Florida
I'm married to a man father I'm fully
wholly embraced by everything going on
here in this sort of New Freedom
conservative movement and if you were to
listen to the media this is the most
homophobic racist bigoted backwards
place in the world and from where I said
it's literally the freest as the Santa
says the The Citadel of Freedom right
now well I've only been here for a day
so I haven't had much of a chance to
find out yeah but yeah I'd look but they
haven't come to get you yet they haven't
uh yes they haven't and and what's
interesting to me is that we we're sort
of in the position now because we've
been lied to so much and because the
words have been debased to such an
extent I they they they could say that
you know DeSantis whatever I wouldn't I
wouldn't be likely to believe it right
and I actually think that's such a
that's a damn shame right it's not just
a shame it's very dangerous in my
opinion because if you look look
I was not a fan of Donald Trump I remain
not a fan of Donald Trump but as as
someone whose Jewish ancestors fall on
the Eastern Front to defeat Nazi Germany
it is an insult
to them and to me to imply that this guy
whatever your view of his politics whose
daughter married the Jewish man who him
who he then appointed to serve him
he is a Nazi he hates Jews he's
anti-semitic uh it's an insult and it's
dangerous because the problem we have is
some people are Nazis and we have to be
able to say that's a Nazi that's not an
Arty and for that to be believed and so
this erosion of language is people don't
understand how dangerous it is I think
it is genuinely a major issue you know
one of the things that I said I think
the day after Trump was elected and I
didn't vote for him the first time I did
the second time uh I said You know guys
let's pause for a second here because
let's see what happens but once you keep
calling him Hitler and all his
supporters Nazis it's not what you're
doing to them it's what you're doing to
yourself because you're painting
yourself in a corner now if the economy
is doing well and we're not going to war
I mean a bunch of things that were
happening under him you can't suddenly
be like ah you know that Hitler pretty
good pretty you know pretty good right
and and so that's I think has led to a
lot of the hysteria it has and uh you
know I think while you and I wouldn't be
sitting here without social media
uh social media's had a big impact on on
the way we communicate and and not in a
good way yeah because do you see it as a
net negative actually I I always
struggle with that it's like wow look at
my life look what I've been able to do
and and all the people I've been able to
connect with and the new ideas that we
can all share or even old ideas that we
can finally share in a sensible way
right and yet
the anxiety the craziness the Doom
scrolling
huh
obviously you and I being able to sit
here and have this conversation is worth
Society being screwed for the next few
decades I think when we are you know
we're living through the next
information revolution you know the
invention of the printing press you get
two centuries of religious war and and
all that craziness that's what we're
going through now
can you stop this I mean there was a guy
who tried called Ted didn't yeah
what are you going to do so I think what
we have to do is make the best of what
we've got and but that starts with
acknowledging the sort of problems that
social media has caused because we now
live in a world where
making sure that what you say sounds
good is much more important than being a
good person
and that's a problem that's a problem
because you know from I don't know if
this is the same in in here but in in on
the British comedy circuit anyone who
was really nice on stage was probably
groping a woman in a group oh yeah so
it's always the biggest feminists on
stage that are there exactly and vice
versa the people whose material was
grotesque and offensive and whatever
they're usually the people that actually
were really decent behind the scenes so
um and the other thing is you know
sometimes I think people wonder why our
institutions have been so captured and I
think a big part of the reason is
Progressive ideas sound good
all things to all men I mean you know
equality for everybody and you know I
grew up in the Soviet Union we saw all
that but we didn't have social media now
the problem with a lot of the
classically liberal and conservative
ideas is they don't sound good well I
have to take responsibility for my life
well I have agency what some things are
my fault
who wants to hear that right right well
they do sound good once they're a little
older but I suppose for when you're 15
they don't sound good and now people are
perpetually 15. that that's I think
that's exactly what's going on and so
yeah we're all gonna as a society have
to have to come up with some answers to
to what we do about it do you see any of
it as a fault or or a flaw within
Classical liberalism itself I mean when
I've watched so many and I want to talk
about a moment on your podcast that
really went viral with Sam Harris but
when I've seen so many of sort of the
old school Libs just kind of collapse
under this thing and become either go
woke or become largely irrelevant
because they can't make sense of the new
world do you think that there's like an
actually inherent problem with Classical
liberalism
well I think the people you're talking
about this or what you'd call lives were
in the UK we would call center left
right right right so that's where the
words can be a little yeah confusing but
I think people will know what we mean
um I think their problem is they don't
want to be me and they don't want to be
you that's their problem and they're
cowards they're terrified they're
terrified of the extremists on their own
team and so they won't speak up and when
they do
what happens they get called right-wing
and all the rest of it so a lot of them
you know we saw your journey and we were
inspired by that a lot of people see
your journey or our journey and they're
very put off by that they don't want to
be called names that they're
uncomfortable with so I think did you
have a moment where you decided to walk
through the fire because I I think about
people always ask me about that and I I
don't know that I I know I had my wake
up moments you know my moment with Larry
Elder and this or that but I don't know
that I had like an actual moment like
sitting down with myself being like
let's just go through I just I just kept
going yeah
you know it was never that hard for me
if I'm being honest uh
you know when you've got grandparents
who who spent 15 years in the gulag for
saying the wrong thing when you come
from a country in which people were were
beaten to death and tortured to death
and executed for for speaking their mind
it's not you know people say people say
oh you're so brave
come on with this that's silly uh so I
was never really that that scared of the
and plus I'm a contrarian so I I
I like pissing people off I like saying
the thing that people don't want to hear
even that is true and that needs to be
said uh so I I embrace I I'm quite a
combative person by Nature I try I try
to temper that but I I quite like it to
be honest uh I wouldn't have it any
other way yeah it's interesting I think
one of the things that kept me sane
throughout this was I didn't do this for
friends and I think a lot of people do a
lot of this for friends and to be liked
and it's nice to be like I'm not saying
it isn't but my best two friends one of
them I met the first day of kindergarten
1981 and one of them I met the first day
of third grade you know a couple years
after that so so as I saw people kind of
like me and then they suddenly didn't
like me I was just kind of like all
right well and it's still painful I
remember you're going through that I
don't remember you would talk a lot
about you know this friend and that
friend and I understand that yeah uh for
me it was easier because if I'm being
honest I never liked 99 of the people I
working with uh it must be nice being a
total contrarian I would say I'm like a
begrudging contrary or something no
there must be something very refreshing
about the full thing I like the space
I'm in now I I really get on with people
in this space because we we operate in
the same way uh but comedians tend to to
process the world through emotions and I
don't and I get very tired of people who
believe things because those things make
them feel good as opposed to because
they're true so uh you know when I was
doing stand-up I would leave a gig the
moment I was done 90 of the time you
didn't want to sit down with all the
alcoholics and complain about all the
problems in the world and not have a
dollar no no and you know I I'm even
though I'm an adopted Brit I have a much
more American attitude about life I want
to be successful I want to be great I
want to be the best at what I do I don't
mean you know have the most subscribers
I would I just I want to get better I
want to improve I want to create I want
to build a team I want to build a
business I want to build a YouTube
channel and that that's not an attitude
you're allowed to have and in the
British sort of creative arts you know
uh it's funny I remember I met a guy who
I haven't seen for a long time and he
had just opened on tour for Ricky
Gervais which is a huge achievement
right huge achievement and I was like oh
man congratulations it was like oh yeah
I got really lucky I was like
what do you mean I've seen you work for
10 years yeah yeah but we do have that
sort of you know you've got to play
yourself down a little bit in in the UK
and I I can't do that so let's talk
about one of the guys and uh you said to
me right before you know my rules I have
no rules on this show and you said to me
right before we started that you have no
rules in essence but you don't like to
talk bad about about former guests and I
I try not to do that as well
um but I want to show that will be
tested right no right well I I hate to
tell you it's going to really be tested
the longer you do this but yeah in any
event we played a clip we played two I
think two clips from you over over the
last year I want to show people both of
them the first one I want to throw to is
you guys had Sam Harris on the podcast
uh this is what about six months ago now
it was it was closer to a year ago it
was sort of August July August yeah it's
about eight months or so ago whatever it
is our last trip to that do you want to
set it up in any way or should we just
throw to it and then we'll uh no you go
for it all right so let's throw it in
the clip I mean 100 button at that point
Hunter Biden literally could have had
the corpses of children in his basement
I would not have cared right it's like
it's there's nothing
first of all it's Hunter Biden right
it's not it's like it's not Joe Biden
but even if Joe like even whatever scope
of Joe Biden's corruption is like if you
if we could just go down that rabbit
hole endlessly and and understand that
he's getting kickbacks from 100 Biden's
deals in Ukraine or whatever else right
or China
it is
infinitesimal compared to the corruption
we know Trump is involved in it's like
it's like it's like a firefly to the sun
right I mean like there's just it
doesn't even it doesn't even stack up
against Trump University right Trump
University as a story is worse than
anything that could be in in Hunter
Biden's laptop in my view right now
that's not that doesn't answer the
people who say it's still completely
unfair
to not have looked at the laptop in a
timely way and to have shut down the you
know the New York post's twitter account
like that that's a just a conspiracy
that's a left-wing conspiracy to deny
the presidency to Donald Trump
absolutely it was absolutely right but I
think it was warranted right and I'm and
again it's a coin toss as to whether or
not Sam I'm sorry that particular person
I'm really sorry I was the one that said
we should move on but you've just said
something I really struggled over there
which is
the kids in the basement you no no
the kids in the basement I'm interested
in democracy you're saying you are
content
with the left-wing conspiracy to prevent
somebody being democratically re-elected
as president well no I'm content well so
but the thing is it's just not left wing
right so Liz Cheney is not left wing
right Liz Cheney
to prevent somebody from being
Democratic it's not a good no but
there's nothing conspiracy it's not it
was a conspiracy out in the open it does
but it doesn't matter if it doesn't
matter what parts conspiracy what parts
out in the open I mean I think it's like
if people get together and talk and talk
about what should we do about this
phenomenon you know if it's like if
there was an asteroid hurtling toward
Earth
and and we got in a room together with
all of our friends and had a
conversation about what we could do to
deflect its course right is that a
conspiracy man that that is something
because I know that Sam obviously was
influential in your political and I
guess uh cultural Evolution and you sort
of tried to save him there but well
I'd like Sam a lot and I would say that
out of all the guests that we've ever
had on the show he's probably been
present company accepted the the
nicest person that we've had in terms of
we actually on that day had massive Tech
issues and he sat there for 40 minutes
waiting for us to get the camera rolling
he was incredibly and he made us feel
really comfortable about that so on a
personal level I really like Sam and
that's why you know I was sort of got
Sam there's a cliff there please don't
walk off it yeah and you know his his
comments speak for themselves I thought
that
um I disagree with what he said
fundamentally and I think you could see
that on both our faces right right but
you were trying to sort of save him but
the the only reason I'm really showing
it is not to to bash him it truly isn't
but it seemed like it almost in some
ways a uh final nail in the coffin on
this odd Adventure that he's been on
intellectually over the last couple
years going all in on the the Trump hate
that you described earlier related to
other people or thanking Jack Dorsey for
banning Donald Trump on Twitter when the
whole idea of what we were all doing was
in free speech so that's why I think the
moment caught fire the way that it did
yeah I I think the reason that that clip
went super viral was was that
Sam showed people the thing that they
always suspected was there yeah
motivating the the thing and it it's
it's a hard one because I you know the
first thing I did actually after it
happened is email Simon just make sure
he was okay because
it's not easy you mean after it had gone
by after it had gone viral just to make
sure that you know he was okay because I
wouldn't want a guest to come on the
show and then you know who knows what
happens from there I was kind of
concerned to be honest but he was very
generous and actually he said he thought
we did a great job
um
yeah I I think with with with that my
fundamental disagreement with Sam about
this is that
it's a threat misassment in my opinion
and if you exaggerate the threat in your
head there you're then willing to take
actions that you otherwise would not and
violent principles that you otherwise
would not and we saw this as you know
during covert uh people get scared
people overestimate the nature of the
threat and then the reaction they demand
from their government or they themselves
have is just completely out of whack and
I so uh destroying democracy to prevent
Donald Trump that doesn't make sense to
me personally right so let's talk about
the Kobe thing a little bit because uh
obviously it has framed almost
everything over the last couple of years
uh I went radically
anti-mandate and pro-freedom literally
moved my entire life across the country
in the midst of it because of all of the
craziness uh I sense you're you're in a
similar spot when it came to mandates
and things of that mattered but what was
your Evolution like related uh I
supported the first lockdown in the UK
we didn't know what was going on and we
were told was very dangerous and while
we should all be skeptical of course of
what the mainstream media tell us in
that sort of situation I do think as a
responsible citizen you do have a duty
to at least consider it and remember
what we were told in the UK is this is
going to be three weeks we're going to
solve the problem everything's fine they
told you three weeks three we got two
weeks two weeks they told us either two
weeks or 15 days they were always
working with one extra business the
longest three weeks in human history
those turned out to be so at the
beginning uh I supported the first
lockdown uh
you know but from there I just felt that
we went in a dystopian Direction very
very quickly uh and on the basis of data
that to me didn't seem reasonable uh we
were forced to wear these face nappies
that don't do anything uh as we know and
not only do we know that now we knew
that before we knew that before right uh
and I think it signals to me something I
talk about in the book actually
that we are importing ways of doing
business that are fundamentally
anti-western and and we have this from
the UK Neil Ferguson uh not not the
historian who we love Yeah but but uh
the guy who was essentially behind
advising the government to have the
lockdowns he was a scientist that must
have been tougher our Neil Ferguson yeah
I imagine so uh so he uh said in I think
it's a Times article that we didn't know
lockdowns were possible until we saw
what the Chinese were doing I mean what
a horrific and I think this speaks to
something else you know I I one of the
things I mentioned in in the book is
most people don't know do you know where
political correctness comes from the
term itself the term political
correctness
I don't think so Soviet Union and it
never had anything to do with protecting
the rights of minorities and not
offending people or being nice or
anything like that it was a very simple
thing to tell people like my ancestors
comrade this is actually correct but it
is Politically Incorrect and what that
means is uh you are not adhering to the
party line right and to me the fact that
we adopted Chinese a Chinese style
response to that sort of threat
um signals that we are moving in in an
authoritarian Direction and and the
thing that scared me most this is look
this is not a popular thing to say but I
think it's true at least in in our
country
it wasn't the politicians that did this
it was the people they wanted this Paul
after Paul after Paul after Paul you
know 20 of people want nightclub shut
down permanently irrespective of covert
irrespective of covert day
they want to shut down things just
because there's an opportunity to do so
uh where Mars on public transport 40 or
30 forever doesn't matter if there's
covert
you know we shout to bed and and I'm
really uncomfortable with what happened
you know you know what day it was for me
that I realized what nonsense it was
because I'm I'm with you uh the first
two weeks I granted everybody a Long
Leash and I can even Grant in retrospect
I can even Grant a longer leash we were
so hit in the head it was the first time
we had dealt with this I think we've all
learned a lot and hopefully a certain
portion of us won't do it again but for
me it really was day 15. once they said
two weeks to stop the spread and we
rolled into day 15 because it changed
overnight they kept saying the new
normal and once I started hearing The
New Normal everywhere it was on
commercials it was on NBC CNN I was like
whoa whoa
something else is going on here and then
that clearly bore out to be true but
what do you think that says about human
nature or the spiritual side of what's
going on here that we we actually wanted
it and from an American perspective I
don't know if it's quite true from a UK
perspective we re-voted we voted in a
lot of the same people that did this
Gretchen Whitmer Gavin Newsom the list
goes on and on
well we know this throughout history I I
sort of joked uh during the pandemic at
some point that you know this is at
least the one thing that hasn't happened
yet is we haven't blamed the Jews but
but we've we did just about everything
it was just about everything else right
so when people are scared when people
when bad things are going on people you
know they the the instincts come out and
the worst side comes out and it's like
human beings you know on an individual
level when you're having a bad day all
your worst aspects of your personality
are magnified and the best ones are
dampened right and I tell you what it
was for me for me it was uh what
happened uh over BLM in the UK that
really showed me that this is uh a
complete nonsense because
we we had this first lockdown which I
and almost everybody obeyed to the
letter and had a lot of respect for
there was another moment when uh the sun
first came out it's a rare occurrence in
England uh and uh some some people had
the temerity to go outside on Sunday my
God uh and this was by this point it was
very clear that this virus does not
spread well Outdoors uh and I said on
Twitter that you know I think people
should be allowed to sunbathe and I it
was I I I I don't know what I could
compare it to the reaction that I got so
I thought people were starting to lose
their minds but then we saw the whole
country hadn't been having been locked
down for this entire time uh
BLM happens
and suddenly protest outside without
masks are a public health intervention
they were actually pro-public Health
that's where we were told because racism
was a bigger they're to be celebrated
there to be encouraged
if you want to live in a western liberal
democracy in which people are judged on
the content of their character
that can't happen
that can't happen uh and and to me that
was the moment when I just went okay
this this is done and to the point where
um you know we were I remember going to
speaking at a protest
in Parliament Square outside the the
houses of Parliament in in London uh
when they were trying to force medical
staff
to have a vaccine in order to to remain
um to remain in in their post and it's
interesting I I've never told the story
publicly or maybe no I don't think I
have
um when my wife gave birth she had quite
a long and difficult labor and they were
supposed to be at home she wanted to
give birth at home but we had to go to
hospital because it wasn't going well
and it was a long and difficult and
scary and all the rest of it but as it
was looking like you know things were
going to get really bad uh this Midwife
came in who was a high level Midwife
than the other ones and she was like
this Angel she was incredible and she
helped my wife she give birth naturally
it was just like she she fixed the thing
it was beautiful he was amazing and
afterwards all the other midwives had
left and she was just filling out some
forms and she was asking us various
questions and my wife who was pregnant
at the time the vaccine came out wasn't
going to have it
and this Midwife was reading the thing
she goes no this asking various
questions then she said are you
vaccinated and I you know I my wife's
just given birth I'm sort of trying to
look after her I I don't want to you
know but equally I I don't want you know
this medical professional to think that
we're the wackos and whatever so I said
uh well you know we were pregnant and I
started sort of fumbling for an answer
that that will please both sides which
is unlike me uh and
um she said oh don't worry I'm not
vaccinated
and and we had a conversation I said so
you must have you must have not you must
have felt really bad when the government
was trying to force you to be vaccinated
and she said I was going to quit
that woman would not have been there if
the government had carried on with that
program and so you know for all the crap
we took for standing up on that issue
um I felt that to me was the ultimate
Vindication that that happened it's it's
a it's a story that I I really
appreciate and and think about a lot you
know and that's when you know we talked
about being brave and whatever you just
it's nonsense we just gotta we all got
to say what we believe so since the walk
thing is kind of what what I think has
really put you on the map do you see
the precursor to covid with all of the
woke craziness that we were dealing with
before Kobe then covid comes now
everyone's brains are completely broken
does it seem like sort of Fairly obvious
to you that we're at where we're at
right now that if you had three years or
whatever we had of like hardcore
wokeness online then we get three years
of covid and now we're just in this like
post covid woke broken weirdness yeah I
think covert broke a lot of people's
brains left and right because
you and I both know social media is not
good for you and we all spent three
years just downloading Twitter into our
heads right A lot of people did so I
think that's had a huge impact but I
think the bigger the bigger question is
we don't have a shared consensus anymore
we don't and how can you how can you
have a you know you you talk about
Classical liberalism that means part of
that means the ability to discuss ideas
and debate ideas how can you debate
ideas if you don't agree on reality
right there is no basis in reality and I
actually it's interesting because uh I
don't know if you saw Gavin newsom's
non-campaign campaign ads recently you
saw that we played them I don't know if
you know that I don't like that yeah I
imagine so but what I found interesting
about that is he's he was using all the
quote-unquote tropes yeah of people on
the right right and and so he's
basically saying I believe in Freedom no
it's incredible that he has the goal to
put any of this in his mouth it's
incredible and everyone's the reverse of
the truth we went through the list right
but but they're people who believe that
and there are people on the other side
who believe the opposite and so that
lack of shared consensus is really where
the problems are so you got a solution
on that what do you I mean I talk about
this all the time what do we do about
that I mean I I know I I think it was a
very tactical move that Gavin did that
to use the words freedom to talk about
all of the things that are happening in
Florida as if they're negative relative
to Freedom yeah and that he taught that
we're the ones Banning books not true
it's actually him trying to find To Kill
a Mockingbird in California state
schools all of these things you know
women's rights and your own body it's
like wait you were the one trying to
inject everybody with your stuff you
know all the nonsense but what do we do
with that as that as that continues to
break down well
I oscillate between two different
thoughts on this I've talked a lot about
the post-work future because to me a lot
of the people who I would hope were on
our side once I see them as equally
abominable now as as the woke the
anti-work is becoming a parody of itself
um and what would be an example of that
uh there are many examples of that I
mean there are a lot of people on the
anti-work side who don't believe in free
speech they don't believe in debating
people's ideas they believe in
destroying people uh there are a lot of
people who are unwilling to have a
discussion with somebody they disagreed
and they spend their entire time owning
people now though I go on the BBC and
make them look bad and we'll put a clip
out but that's not that's not who I am
and it's not what I do right and I think
generally
look it's hard to be and we talked about
earlier it's hard to be anti-something
and be constructive
it's hard objective right and so for me
the answer you when I talk about going
for a post-work future culturally at
least what that means to me is
I don't believe that before we started
we talked about the NBA yeah right which
was very heavily politicized I don't
think the average person the the average
person wants to turn on the NBA and
watch a bunch of players talking about
BLM I also by the way don't think you
want to turn on the NBA and watch a
bunch of players talking about how CRT
is is is is destroying schools and all
of that I have this strange feeling they
want to watch some some basketball
dribble the damn ball how about that
well you know that is a loaded phrase
now because if he wanted it but but for
me uh you know I think people want to
enjoy the content uh I think that is
also true of drama of comedy of all of
these things so uh as as people crave
that more and more I think that's where
we're gonna end up and I think it
behooves Comedians and people who who
are in the creative space to try and uh
perhaps you you attack both sides and
therefore bring them together or bring
them together just by bringing them
together by focusing on the things that
are common to all people on on the story
drama for example doesn't have to be
anti-work or work just has to be good
and the problem certainly I don't know
about this country but in the UK with
comedy it just got ruined by
you know uh Mark the week which was a
huge show Mass report which was a huge
show that I used to write on actually
they both go just got destroyed by being
excessively political in One Direction
and also by an artificial focus on
people's faces instead of how good they
were at writing or performing or
whatever right um so I think part of the
answer it just lies into not going back
but going forward to a place where not
everything has to be about politics and
I think that's part of it however
you know I was on Michael malice's uh
Show recently and he
you know I was talking about how I'm
concerned about what's happening in this
country just as an outsider observing
about the heatedness of everything and
um
he said well look you're right but I
don't think there's a there's a there's
a pressure valve release that's going to
happen because you know if Trump runs uh
the heat is going to be higher and
they're what they're going to stop
calling him fascist
um so it's difficult I think culturally
what we've got to do is play to the 80
of people in the middle who who don't
care about either right it's uh malice
is sat in that very chair and said
something very similar it's funny
because he oscillates I think between
that black pill and the book obviously
was was the white pill
um it seems to me we just have to figure
out how to build new things and separate
from them that I agree with malice
they're never going to stop the question
is can we build fast enough to have
lasting things before they take
everything that was was good from you
and and good from us yeah and the one
thing I'm really trying uh to to think
about a lot and I think becoming a
father really helped me with this to to
become a little bit more empathetic to
people
um we were young and stupid once as well
and and these woke kids they don't know
any better I think we have to remember
that they're open to persuasion you know
I don't know if you saw my Oxford Union
speech is that the other clip that's not
a character right so I really tried to
speak to people in a way that they could
hear
um and I think that's also part part of
what we've got to be doing I think we uh
we have to be less partisan ourselves we
all do we all do and I think there there
are there are things that I agree with
left-wing people on and there are things
that I agree with right when people on
and I I try to just find that middle and
speak to them and and one of the things
that therefore happens is I kind of
deliberately actually piss off elements
of our audience we both do on purpose uh
to sort of to prune the extremists uh
and I think that's that's the way you
you you culturally do that whether our
politics can survive the social media
age that's a very different conversation
right it's interesting because when I
was going through my political Awakening
and the show was taking off and then I
suddenly had all these lefties who once
loved me now telling me I was a sellout
and all this stuff it was like you mean
I'm selling out to just get endless hate
and like Traverse this new area that I
don't know what the hell is going to
happen and now like now there's this
whole obviously sort of anti-woke thing
but I was just like walking into the
dark like I don't know if this is any of
this is gonna work I'm just doing what I
think but usually people's uh people
have a way of going after your motives
you know what what's interesting is the
more you become a public figure to any
extent the more you realize how
ridiculous what you think about other
people is well I know what Dave Rubin
yeah yeah you know I know you get a lot
of because you know you kind of you
were you started out I'm I'm I'm on the
left and and now you you know you you
picked a team right to some extent right
in terms of politically at least right I
I think you got to pick a team to to
make things happen and you're perfectly
entitled to the view but what's more I
don't understand why people can't
understand that people change their mind
over time and over experience I I
imagine it is not uncommon for someone
who starts out and builds a very
successful business to become more
right-wing on on the economy I mean the
more tax you pay the more it hurts you
know 100 I used to say this all the time
that my life was an example of the ideas
that I was talking about on the show
because I agree with you I wasn't an
expert in a lot of these things but I
was talking to Jordan and I was talking
to Sam and all these guys and then my
career started taking off the business
started being built I was dealing with
taxes and employees and all these things
and I have more of this sort of Freedom
set of ideas and I was like oh I'm
putting these things into place but I'm
trying to build studio in a garage in La
where they have 8 000 regulations and I
can't put a vent over there and now it's
too loud and like so all of the things
that I was talking about I actually was
living through and I think that that
solidified a lot of it and and that's
why I uh you know I never have any
respect for people who make that
argument about you about others people
are people are gonna change their mind
over time they're going to develop their
own uh positions And if someone starts
it out being liberal and then became a
conservative people do that right it's
quite it's quite a normal thing I mean
people have done this for Millennia so
it's a little curious when people go the
other way as they get older right yeah
there are there aren't many examples of
that actually I mean that one is harder
to understand I agree with you yeah it's
harder to understand yeah so let's throw
actually to the to the Oxford Union
speech that you mentioned because this
thing how many views did this thing get
like it's hard to say probably somewhere
between 100 and 200 million views yeah
like across different platforms oh lordy
lordy all right let's go and the only
thing that wokeness has to offer in
exchange is to brainwash Bright Young
Minds like you to believe that you are
victims to believe that you have no
agency to believe that what you must do
to improve the world is to complain
is to protest is to throw soup on
paintings
and we on this side of the house are not
on this side of the house because we do
not wish to improve the world we sit on
this side of the house because we know
that the way to improve the world is to
work is to create it is to build
and the problem with work culture is
that it's trained too many young minds
like yours
to forget about that
thank you very much
the brainwashing element is is pretty
interesting of this that that that's
hard to get people out of they feel like
they have this kind of holistic
worldview and that somehow everyone
before them was an idiot or a
that's the one I can't get over yeah to
be honest I think young people always
think that about other Generations that
you know that thing about when I was 20
my dad was an idiot and by the time I
got 40 he really wisened up yeah like I
think we all experienced that at some at
some level so my issue is that you know
look culture is the brainwashing of of
young people that's what culture is it's
a passing down of certain values and
beliefs about what it is to be human and
how we ought to conduct ourselves right
that's why you have an education system
that's why you have cultural content
that's why we teach children certain
values we are quote unquote brainwashing
them my issue is is that
I I've never understood this you know as
a first generation immigrant I I sort of
people want to tell me that I'm a victim
and I've never understood and it doesn't
really matter if it's true or not what
matters is is it useful and that's my
issue with all of this stuff it's like
why are you teaching children
things that will make them fail why are
you teaching children things that will
make them hurt things that will make
them anxious things that will make them
depressed why are you not teaching them
look you believe in climate change go
for it right go and fix a problem to do
with that issue go and learn and study
for years and work hard and you know
what Melissa Chen I don't know you you
know her well she's a good friend a
wonderful person I love Melissa I think
it was her that tweeted out something a
long time ago she said you can't remain
woke if you build something whether
that's muscle a business or anything and
that's why I would challenge those young
people very bright young people at
Oxford they're the future whether you
like it or not they are going to be the
people running our countries right I
challenge them to recognize that if you
care about whatever the issue it is
you've got to fix it you can't just sit
and mop
were you shocked how many students at
Oxford are buying that stuff because
when I spoke there uh it was a lovely
talk and I did my thing and then there
was some q a and I was getting some
pushback on stuff but I didn't feel it
had fully sort of proliferated
throughout but I I get the sense that
it's deeper now that was that was
probably five years ago when I was on
tour yeah because he taught to say
because you you see you know 400 people
or 500 people who came to see the debate
so what what the mix of it is it's hard
to say I did you know the thing that
really I found very reassuring is I had
a few people uh people would know this
but the debate started like three hours
later than they should have done so we
ended up sitting in the pub waiting and
there was uh there was this girl who
came up to me and she could not believe
she said so do you think they're awoke
people in the UK
uh well uh yeah and sure so you think
they're awoke people in the media oh
yeah and she was like so give me an
example and I give her an example and we
went we went round and round for an hour
anyway after the debate lady I got a bit
after the debate she comes over to me
and asks for a selfie so you know we
gotta we gotta be we gotta be willing to
try to change people's minds and I I
have hope for young people uh because I
was young and stupid and probably I'm
still to some extent both those things
um and you know people are persuadable
and you persuaded me your guest
persuaded me and I believe that we can
persuade others what about the people
that are pushing it sort of I don't want
to say blindly but did you see a clip uh
about a month and a half ago on Real
Time with Bill Maher where he asked
Bernie Sanders if you know if he knew
the difference between equity and
equality did you happen to see this I
didn't see that one no so it's a really
incredibly enlightening moment do you
know the difference between equity and
inequality I mean it's basically saying
to him do you know the difference
between socialism and capitalism in
essence and Bernie fumbles fumbles and
then basically says I don't know and
Bill explains it to him and it's like
well wait a minute you you've been the
prime mover of these ideas from a from a
economic perspective at least I don't
think he realized how it was going to
become racialized and sexualized and
everything else
um but it was clear to me that he just
didn't even know what he was talking
about that doesn't surprise me I
mentioned Bernie in an immigrants level
at to the West because uh it boggles my
mind how anyone in this country takes
him seriously this is a guy who
honeymooned in the Soviet Union where he
would have had exactly the same
experience as every other Westerner
coming to the Soviet Union they would
have been they would have been taken to
some fake right wedding where fake KGB
agents were having a fake wedding and
then they would be taken on some kind of
trip every movement would be controlled
and these are the people who came back
from the Soviet Union I can't remember
if it was I I don't want to slander dead
people but I can't remember who it was
somebody one of these Darlings of the
left came back from the Soviet Union in
1938 as people millions of my answers
you know my countrymen and women were
loving and said I've never eaten as well
as I did in the Soviet Union these
gullible clowns in the west who have
never experienced socialism have never
experienced communism who sell simple
but false ideas to people they don't
deserve to be taken seriously they don't
and they don't offer any solutions uh
the solutions that they offer will be
counterproductive and hurt people in
this country and around the world it
boggles my mind that people don't
understand that but they don't when you
I know you've only been how many days in
America you're in Florida for a day but
you've been in America yeah we've been
in America for a week in a bit now for
about a week and how much longer are you
here another week in a bit all right so
you got two some odd weeks in America
you're bouncing around to some different
states I assume yeah yeah
um do you sense uh or maybe it's a
little premature that the Federalist
system that we have here where Florida
can be so different than California is
the Escape Route of all of this that's
really been my Saving Grace in all of
this that by picking up moving my life
my family my businesses Etc that I have
Roots now in a place that my my ideas
and the things that I care about can
flourish and they couldn't flourish I
didn't have to leave the country in
other words where it would be trickier
for someone from the UK or someone from
Canada you kind of got it you're very
mild in the way you describe it you
can't it's not tricky it's impossible uh
during covid we there was no part of the
country that was better than the one
that I was living in
um and and even within the European
Union which were no longer members of is
that mind-blowing to you I mean just
knowing UK is not not unbelievably
massive but like there's obviously some
Geographic variation in London is very
different than going out you know even
two hours in any direction that you
don't have that much flexibility well
it's kind of the way in most countries
actually so what is mind blown to me is
the incredible situation you've got here
and I love it uh you know of course
America like any country has problems
but I love that part of it uh I I love I
love this I think this is a brilliant
country I think people don't say that
enough people don't hear that enough uh
if you're growing up in in America or or
anywhere in the west really but
particularly in the United States right
now you're the luckiest person in the
history of humanity and uh and people
and the reason we are where we are Dave
is people have forgotten that and it's
become an unfashionable thing to say and
a dangerous thing to say for some you
know some people feel really shy about
saying it and I that's why as as
speaking as a first generation immigrant
you know I feel a duty yeah I feel a
genuine duty to remind people of that
yeah trust me you spend a little more
time in Florida with some of the Cubans
who you know gastro or their parents did
or whatever it's like
these people free they'll be by the time
you spend to 24 hours here you're gonna
it's gonna be in you even more as
Francis always says you know communism
is a great red pill yeah that's probably
the ultimate red yeah what else has been
on your mind lately like what you know I
know we could do the woke thing always
and the slight sort of differences
between the old liberals and whatever
but what else have you been sort of
thinking about lately
huh well every time we come to America
first of all on a personal level we're
like okay we've got to come and come
come in we gotta move here you know so
you really feel that now you feel that
do you feel that more as a father
actually I feel that less as a father
that's actually the one thing that holds
me back because
I have to say I think I speak for a lot
of parents now in this country and
elsewhere which is like you give you
create this Miracle of Life
you nurture it you look after it you
give it everything you possibly can to
do and then you send it off
to
and I mean the stuff that that yeah like
so that to me is terrifying because I
think in this country you guys are doing
worse on that issue actually the
transition in particular and and the
sexualization of children you guys are
doing worse here than we are in the UK
do you fear though that it's just a
matter of time I mean BLM the idea that
you guys had a BLM in in the UK where
your cops in London don't have guns and
there was no problem I mean I hate to
tell you but oh I'd go back in three
months right you might have a problem on
your hands um I think we're actually
making progress on the transition
believe it or not and I think one of the
reasons that is is that it's not a uh
partisan issue actually uh you know
really so you're left there the labor
party is not all about this the way our
Democrats are the labor party mostly
mostly is but most or as much of the
pushback culturally and in sort of in
our space and elsewhere is is not from
people on the right it's from gender
critical uh women some feminist some not
you know Posey Park who we were one of
the first people to ever interview on in
a long format oh is that right yeah yeah
that video is on that video got taken
down as hate speech from YouTube and
then because it was reinstated thank God
the strides and effect it's now 1.3
million views for a channel that at the
time had that on a hundred thousand
subscribers or something uh so it's
people like her and what that opens up
is is the opportunity for people who are
not on the right people like uh JK
Rowling uh people like Rosie Duffield he
was a labor mp uh to bravely step
forward uh and genuinely bravely unlike
us you know these people get rape
threats and death threats and all the
rest of it uh and and join forces with
others
um and and actually tackle that issue
the Tavistock Clinic which was doing a
lot of these transitions I mean some of
the stuff that's come out in the reports
I mean people should look into that
because it's absolutely terrifying
um that's been shut down now that
doesn't mean we're not going to continue
to have issues with it but we we are
making some progress uh Nicola sturgeon
the I feel for my first minister of
Scotland where they had did you follow
the story I'm not sure a guy who raped
two women uh guy right two women uh
claimed he was a woman and wanted to be
in a women's prison Francis many
versions of that yeah yeah uh we we call
it prison onset gender dysphoria you get
to the courtroom suddenly off I Feel
Like a Woman yeah
um and so but but my point is that is
being aired it is being talked about is
being discussed on on mainstream
television properly uh and we are making
progress doesn't mean we don't have a
long way to go but I I fear that
my concern with the way that this issue
has been discussed in this country and I
say this is an outsider what do I know
but it's just if if enough people keep
saying the libs are Trends in the kids
you're going to get to a position where
that makes it difficult for left-wing
people to step forward and talk about
this as well do you see what I'm saying
and I think because of that we're
actually making better progress on that
particular issue than you guys are in
this country so that issue is the main
the main one that's holding me back
actually about moving here but the thing
I love about it is you know well I
wouldn't worry about that because
there'll be plenty of states where your
kids will be just fine well exactly
Florida uh as long as it stays purple
is basically the right estate in the
country in some ways I mean DeSantis won
by 20 points yeah super majorities on
both sides nobody's coming for the gays
nobody's coming for the black people
it's just fine here that's reassuring
yeah uh and so
uh it's like I'm sitting on the board of
Tourism yeah no you're like you're not
black organs still be okay I don't think
I can handle I mean how you boys get any
work done in this year I have no idea
but uh but my my point is apart from my
concerns about what's happening to
Children uh this country's great it's
great you want you want you want to
build a business sure go for it you want
to do this sure will help you like
that's the attitude and that to me is
the most inspiring thing and that's this
isn't me you know on Britain
because I love Britain too but but my
temperament I think is is more suited
here so I see probably in the next five
years we're gonna end up here so that's
on a personal level in terms of sort of
society and culturally we talked about
it already we're gonna have to work out
what to do about social media
um and that's that's a really tough one
that's a really really tough one let me
ask you one other thing which is that I
just finished watching I think it's
season five of the crown first off did
you watch the crown no it would be
irrelevant you'll know about the
monarchy to be able to ask my question I
really enjoyed the show and what I what
I putting aside any of the specifics of
the of the episodes this idea that
that the monarchy exists over time and
that it is constant I mean the whole
point of the show is it's it's the
constant battle between modernization
and conservatism and that something
should last beyond a labor government or
a conservative government and in some
ways I watch it and I think boy we could
use a little bit of that in America like
like something separate from our daily
you've got to go Republican this time
you've got to go Democrat this time
because it it it separates the sort of
big ideas from the day-to-day politics
and I wonder what you think of that if I
explained it in the somewhat sufficient
fashion look having
a thing that brings people together
is important this is what we've lost
right and I and and the monarchy
you know we were in the transition as
everyone seems to be on that issue as
well uh you know the the passing of the
queen
was mourned I think to such an extent
not only because she was this
extraordinary person but because
you know people see the the England of
their youth going away uh and I think
for a lot of people it was that extra
bit meaningful because it kind of marked
the passing of the oil and we it remains
to be seen whether under the current
King that continuous thing that thing
goes on I think according to the show at
least which I think is fairly factual I
mean he really was pushing for change
all along you know from from youth so
and if he makes and if he makes the
mistake that his younger son made which
is to start weighing in on politics uh I
don't think there will be any way to
defend the monarchy at that point
because the monarchy's purpose is not to
be party political or partisan and once
you start weighing in on these uh very
you know divisive issues
um as as a neutral Observer who's
supposed to just provide the backdrop
against which society takes its uh
course uh then they're going to be in a
lot of trouble so I hope he doesn't do
uh
Constantine I'm glad you made it across
the pond I'm glad that I had a little
something to do with the adventure that
you're on and uh we will do it again
thank you very much Dave it's great to
be on the show
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell